foreign
okay so New York Times comes out in uh a
couple couple days ago the New York
Times the Dirty Little Secret of credit
card reward programs now for years I've
been saying
they work they absolutely do work and
people always call us and like oh you're
telling me that you don't take free
flights and they for sure do if you're
just swiping the card I got a buddy who
puts a hundred percent of his life on
these cards everything on the card so
that and he pays off every month and he
just does it for the for the free free
miles or free whatever sure that's a
real thing that happens now most people
don't pay it off every month and they're
like no I was just going through bro and
they don't but fair enough there are
people who do
and
my buddies were always surprised that I
didn't participate and I wasn't me
trying to take a moral High ground or
anything like that
but I didn't want to participate in this
program because I knew that these credit
card companies are not my friend they
don't like me they're not hooking me up
because I'm hooking them up it's not
like yeah bro let's do this we're in
this together I'll buy some stuff you
give me free flights that's not how it
works
somebody is paying for my flights and as
I dug into it a few years ago it
appeared to me
that the single mom with three kids who
can't float the price of eggs and the
increase in gas prices and the natural
gas prices she was paying for my flights
because she was having to put this stuff
on a credit card conceivably to survive
and so my free flights were being paid
for by people who had way less and were
struggling to to make it and turns out
who was right turned into studies and
data that's incredible this is why okay
tell us about this okay so the you know
it goes on to talk about hey your these
swipes you're using to get first class
airfare and trips and all your Awards
it's it's not from nothing the credit
card perks for educated usually Urban
Pros are subsidized by people who have
less so poor consumers are ultimately
footing the bill and in 2022 a Federal
Reserve data show that the cost of
rewards as a share of total transaction
volume on these credit cards increased
25 percent from 2015 through 2021 and so
what's interesting John is the data was
so clear in this study it showed that 15
billion dollars in reward value moved
from the poor to the rich from the
unsophisticated folks who couldn't pay
their bills on time to the affluent
wealthy and no normal people go well
yeah that's how the system is set up
John
so I'm just going to take advantage of
that why would I not but here's what's
Wild a lot of the people that come at us
going John's I can't believe John's
trying to use this moral angle to say
it's not coming from people who have
less than it's coming from swipe fees
from the businesses
and interchange fees and my annual fees
but I looked at Capital ones they put
their shareholder reports out every year
and in Q4 of 2022 it turns out that
two-thirds of their credit card Revenue
came from interest and fees not from The
Interchange not from the other fees
interest so two-thirds is blood diamond
money yeah and let's also
it's also easier to to get on on a high
horse and say Well they're just making
dumb purchases and they don't know
if you've ever spent some time with
people on the margins so many don't know
right they haven't been told they're
just trying to call their way out of the
world that they found themselves in and
they don't know that it's not normal to
roll fees over like this is they don't
know that a 30 APR isn't just the price
of doing life these days and so I
I don't know how people can look in the
mirror and say you know what I'm
comfortable with a single mom trying to
just trying to scratch through life with
her buying my flights because they're
free now like I just can't wrap my head
around to George and the other problem
is we're all paying for this through the
increased cost of goods the United
States has some of the highest credit
card processing costs in the world
typically two to two and a quarter
percent on every purchase and so the
merchants the businesses the small
businesses they have to pass these costs
on to the consumers by charging more for
the products regardless of how you pay
and you see you see some of the local
Merchants that will say here's the price
for if you play with the card oh here's
the cash price it's less and George I it
has I'm sure it's happened to you more
because you're out in the world more
than I am that's true but um I had my
first exchange the other day where I was
at a place I was traveling uh at a
speaking event and I I was out on the
road and they said we don't take cash
here and it was like I'm not gonna do
business with you just just on principle
I'm just not gonna do business with you
wow well the the date is clear here John
lower income consumers are forced to pay
higher prices on the goods they buy but
they rarely receive any benefit from
rewards programs according to the
Federal Reserve and so it's been
tracking all of this and so to put
another way they say credit card awards
are essentially a tax on less affluent
consumers who are much more likely to
pay for the goods with cash debit cards
or standard credit products that accrue
no such rewards so
you know you have a lot of people have a
lot of opinions about this but across
the aisle politically I mean NPR and Vox
and New York Times they're covering the
same thing going hey this isn't innocent
yeah someone is paying for this and it's
either the small business owner or the
single mom but you can't act like this
is just an innocent I'm just going to
rape the rewards your free vacation came
from somewhere and we have to at least
acknowledge that that's right and if you
and and God bless you if you can sleep
at night knowing that um I pay my bills
I do my thing so I if that's that's I
mean if that if you your conscience can
carry that weight more power and even if
you don't have a conscience every single
piece of data shows that you spend more
when you use a credit card right every
piece of data so regardless if you're
saying hey I'm going to use every I'm
going to use my card for everything to
get these rewards the chances are you
overspent to where the rewards were
negligible right you you maybe got a
thousand bucks in rewards you spent more
than a thousand dollars than you were if
you were gonna use a debit card on a
budget or using cash so here's here like
to me the Cornerstone rule is opt out of
the system just opt out man this is like
Matrix style stuff but just opt out of
this I haven't had a credit card in 10
years and I can unequivocally say my
life has been better for it no question
not once have I wondered well they've
got five percent cash back on
restaurants this month so I gotta I'm
gonna switch the card I was hanging out
with some guys the other night they're
all personal finance you know influencer
type guys and they're all showing me the
different cards and this one's made of
three inches of metal and I get this
much rewards and I'm like guys you make
millions of dollars how much money do
you get back in rewards they were like I
probably got two grand worth of value
I went so you're playing this game for
two grand worth of value and you make
millions yeah why yeah exactly
it's a crazy I mean when you put it that
way you go is it like real life Dungeons
and Dragons you're getting paid 200 a
month to overspend and play this game
and support this system yeah it's just
not worth it for me I'm out I'm out I
opt out of the system opt out of the
system